do you still believe in god
so
every night before i go on stage i say a
prayer
um
that word still feels like triggering to
me but i say something before i go to
stage i but in the beginning it was dear
god you know
help me to go out here help my voice to
work help me to to have
to be have good intention to connect
with these people to bring happiness joy
love whatever i'm supposed to do let it
be in the name of
jesus christ amen and then the next year
it was like dear universe or something
whatever's there and then in the name of
whatever is truth and then you know
flash forward to now and it's about to
go on stage tonight
you know if there's anything out there
right
hell yeah and uh but i you know
yeah i still do because it brings me
comfort but do i believe in god
i don't know if there's any god i'm
maybe i'm not an atheist because i feel
like that's to me personally i feel like
that's as crazy as mormonism i'm like
how do you know and how do you know how
does anybody know i don't trust anybody
who tells me they know so i'm somewhere
nothingness but whatever agnostic or
whatever the term is i think that's
where i'm at nobody has any idea i mean
i know sometimes when i'm walking around
and i see like i just see the the earth
i see the sky i see this i go how could
something so beautiful exist
how could we not see the creator in the
creation you know that kind of thing but
you know my logical sort of scientific
self says i don't i think this is all
random yeah we argue about this a lot
me and wayne have arguments like every
day about the simulation theory whether
this is a a simulation
based reality and
and i think wayne is probably you can
speak for yourself about your belief but
are you are you an atheist yeah i'm an
atheist but i think there's a lot of
misconceptions about what that is i
don't it's it's not a claim
like a lot of people think atheism is a
claim that there is no god but it's just
a rejection of a claim
just saying there's no reason to believe
that there is a
a god you guys are a rock band and
everything but think of how things have
changed like you guys are discussing
whether there's a god i mean like led
zeppelin was out on the road i think
[ __ ] people with an octopus you know
what i mean like
it's like what the hell happened
you